À l'est du Groenland, Tasiilaq perdu dans l'Arctique.
Il est 3h du matin, c'est le début de l'été,
Il fait -5 degrés et ces adolescents n'ont pas sommeil.
Dans la nuit blanche et gelée, ils se retrouvent sur
la place du village pour écouter de la pop américaine.
Ce sont mes amis. On est branchés sur
Internet, on regarde des clips sur YouTube.
Et après on essaie de danser comme eux.
Regarde, ils vont te montrer ce qu'ils savent faire.
Les parents, eux, passent la nuit
dans la moiteur du bar du village.
Sur des airs de rock groenlandais, leurs pas
sont plombés par l'alcool qui coule à flots.
On est ici bien loin du Groenland sauvage
et féérique des cartes postales.
Tasiilaq, avec ses 1600 habitants, est la seule
ville dans une région grande comme la France.
Il y a encore un siècle, les habitants, les Inuits,
vivaient ici en autonomie grâce à la chasse et à la pêche.
Mais ce mode de vie a disparu quand les colons danois ont
décidé de sédentariser la population pour fonder une ville.
Routes, écoles, dispensaires sont arrivées
en même temps que la société de consommation.
Comme partout ailleurs, le chômage s'est installé. À Tasiilaq, désormais, les Inuits ne dépendent plus de la nature,
Mais des aides sociales versées par le Danemark.
Chaque début de mois, devant les distributeurs
de ce supermarché, c'est le même défilé.
Les gens là, ils retirent leur argent et
après ils vont faire leurs courses.
Ils achètent beaucoup trop d'alcool. Ce soir, tout le
monde va boire de nouveau. C'est vraiment pénible.
De l'alcool caché derrière ses rideaux pour tenter
de diminuer sa consommation qui fait des ravages.
Chômage, crise identitaire, isolement, autant de facteurs
qui plongent les Groenlandais dans le désarroi.
Tiraillés entre tradition et modernité,
les jeunes sont les plus fragiles.
Mosheys, 21 ans, rêve d'être footballeur mais pour le
moment, il traîne son ennui dans les rues de Tasiilaq.
Déraciné et sans métier, il vivote grâce aux
150€ mensuels que lui alloue le Danemark.
On a besoin de plus de travail, mais en même temps,
s'il y en avait, les gens ne travailleraient pas.
Ils sont trop occupés à boire.
Un manque de perspective fatal à de nombreux habitants. Le Groenland remporte chaque année la palme du désespoir,
Avec le taux de suicide le plus fort au monde,
huit fois plus élevé qu'en France.
Mosheys, lui, a perdu son meilleur ami l'an passé.
Il était bourré quand il a appris que sa copine l'avait trompé.
Il était fou de rage.
Il est rentré chez lui et à cause de l'alcool,
il s'est tiré une balle dans la tête.
Je me suis dit que je n'arriverais
plus à vivre, que j'avais tout perdu.
J'ai pleuré tous les jours. Parfois, je vais
au cimetière, je pleure et je lui parle.
Sous la neige, un terrain grand comme un stade de foot. C'est
ici qu'on enterre en moyenne un nouveau jeune par mois.
Je ne me souviens plus exactement où est
sa tombe. Elle est là-bas, je crois.
C'est à qui de venir sur scène ?
Face à cette détresse, des jeunes ont décidé d'agir.
Cette troupe de théâtre a créé un spectacle qui met en
lumière ce que tout le monde à Tasiilaq cherche à cacher.
Dans la prochaine scène, ce qu'on veut dire, c'est que c'est difficile d'apprendre qu'un ami a mis fin à ses jours.
On va vous le montrer.
J'en ai assez de vivre !
Les jeunes ont beaucoup de problèmes.
Et ils ne peuvent rien dire.
Alors j'ai décidé de les aider et j'ai créé cette mise en scène.
Mais comment tu as pu faire ça ?
Ils raconte simplement leur vie. Vous voyez, ils
pleurent en exprimant toutes leurs souffrances.
Pourquoi moi ?
Des scènes qui vont jusqu'à révéler le plus grand tabou du pays.
Beaucoup de jeunes sont victimes d'abus sexuels.
C'est le plus gros problème ici.
Près d'un tiers des jeunes Groenlandais ont connu
une agression sexuelle, un drame lié à l'alcoolisme,
Qui se joue dans l'intimité des familles et qui
explique en grande partie l'épidémie des suicides.
Le théâtre est alors le moyen d'évacuer les traumatismes.
Au début, on est toujours un peu timide,
mais en fait, ça fait du bien, ça libère !
Oui, on se sent plus fort !
J'ai bien cru que j'allais sombrer, quand j'ai appris ce que mon frère avait fait parce que je me suis retrouvée toute seule.
C'était vraiment terrible, j'étais inconsolable.
Heureusement que j'ai trouvé ici un peu de soutien.
Yo Eltsine, seize ans, et la petite sœur du jeune qui
s'est suicidé l'an passé, le meilleur ami de Mosheys.
Comme chaque après-midi, elle retrouve ses amis du théâtre.
Ils vont dans l'un des rares lieux de Tasiilaq,
Où les jeunes peuvent se mettre à l'abri
autant du froid que de leurs parents.
Quand mes parents buvaient, ils nous disaient des trucs
terribles, du genre qu'ils ne voulaient plus de nous,
Qu'ils attendaient qu'on meure, mon frère et moi.
Quand sa petite copine l'a trompé, mon
frère s'est senti abandonné pour de bon.
J'ai beau aller sur sa tombe, ça ne me console pas.
C'est terrible mais ce chemin du suicide,
on a tous été tenté de le prendre un jour.
Face à cette tentation du pire, le théâtre
offre à ses jeunes une nouvelle donne.
Il se retrouve ce jour là chez le fondateur de la troupe.
Rejetée durant son enfance à cause de son apparence féminine,
Heno, 17 ans, assume aujourd'hui pleinement sa différence.
Dans sa chambre, des posters de stars américaines,
Qui lui ont inspiré son rêve de devenir un jour comédien.
Je veux être une star, c'est mon rêve ! Ici,
c'est ma motivation. Je rêve de décrocher un Oscar.
Les seuls à soutenir ce projet de théâtre, ce sont les parents d'Heno. Ils ont grandi dans les traditions et la pudeur,
Mais se félicitent qu'aujourd'hui des jeunes lèvent enfin le voile.
Je trouve qu'ils ont beaucoup de courage
pour revenir sur ces traumatismes.
Ils s'entraident et c'est une bonne chose. Je suis sûr
qu'ils peuvent faire baisser le nombre de suicides.
Un soutien d'autant plus important que les psychologues,
ici comme dans le reste du Groenland, sont rarissimes.
Le pays, qui compte seulement 57 000 habitants, manque d'effectifs.
Quand un jeune perd l'équilibre, il est accueilli dans cette
maison où une dizaine de personnes formées sur le tas,
Tentent de lui venir en aide.
On a bien un psychologue qui vient chaque mois de Nuuk, la capitale, mais il reste deux ou trois jours. Ça fait court.
Ces éducateurs essaient de rétablir le lien
entre parents et enfants, souvent brisé.
Les parents ont beaucoup de mal à éduquer leurs enfants. Quand ils n'ont pas bu, ils les gâtent beaucoup trop et ils les surprotège.
Et dès qu'ils ont bu, là, ils les oublient complètement.
Dernière répétition avant le spectacle face aux parents.
Les jeunes de la troupe veulent profiter de monter sur scène
pour leur adresser un message sous forme de confession.
Vous vous souvenez de moi ?
Oui, c'est bien moi, celle qui a été délaissée
par ses parents et qui a perdu son seul frère.
Ça n'a pas toujours été simple, mais
aujourd'hui, je suis là, debout.
Alors papa, maman, je vous aime.
J'ai dû élever toute seule mes demi-frères parce
que mes parents, ils ne s'occupaient pas d'eux.
Je me suis sentie si seule.
Papa, Maman, je vous aime, merci.
Nos parents sont en vie, alors on se doit de leur dire merci.
Merci de m'avoir mis au monde.
Sauf que le jour J, les parents ne se sont pas déplacés.
À quelques minutes du spectacle, dans le public,
Il y a surtout les jeunes de Tasiilaq et leurs éducateurs.
Aujourd'hui, notre spectacle est un peu particulier.
On a décidé de vous faire partager les expériences
difficiles que nous avons traversées.
C'est la première fois qu'on en parle.
Ma fille ! Ma fille !
Aux moments clés du spectacle, un
public qui peine à contenir son émotion.
La représentation s'achève et derrière les larmes des jeunes comédiens, il y a la fierté d'avoir brisé le silence.
Le public s'en va à la fois ému et gêné.
Dehors, les sanglots rattrapent les quelques mères présentes.
Le pari est réussi pour la troupe, cette prise de conscience
mènera peut-être Tasiilaq sur le chemin de la guérison,
Avec l'espoir pour la jeunesse de se sentir davantage aimé.